[Music]
kabul's international airport continues
to be overwhelmed with people trying to
flee afghanistan since the taliban took
over the capital on august 15th
as scenes of desperation have played out
the taliban have threatened to block
afghans from leaving the country while
president biden has doubled down on his
deadline for when u.s troops are
scheduled to leave the country
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st the sooner we can finish
the better
each day of operations brings added risk
to our troops
as the deadline looms afghans able to
board evacuation flights face long
journeys to their host countries
starting a resettlement process with
challenges ahead
the path to getting out of the country
hasn't been clear one huge hurdle
documentation
it sounds like from people that we've
interviewed that it mostly comes down to
luck whether you get into the airport or
not you know the first few days of the
evacuation effort it was kind of so
chaotic they were letting a lot of
people in including people who didn't
really have valid
visa or travel documents and now we're
kind of seeing the reverse you know
people even who do have valid american
visas are going up to the gates of the
airport waving them at american troops
or canadian troops and still not getting
into the airport
once they are inside issues with
document verification continue adding to
the bottleneck
in a lot of cases you had people with
you know fake or even no documents
getting into the airport in the first
few days cramming themselves onto planes
getting out of afghanistan and now
partially because all that happened the
us is really prioritizing getting
american citizens and american green
card holders through that gate and it
means more afghans are being left behind
and there's added urgency as the taliban
have threatened retaliation against
americans and others if the u.s remains
past the deadline late wednesday the u.s
embassy urged americans outside the
airport's gates to leave immediately
citing security threats by that point
the u.s and its allies had evacuated
more than 88 thousand people since the
taliban closed in on kabul on august
14th
military transport planes have shuttled
evacuees to hubs in qatar bahrain and
germany with smaller satellite hubs
receiving evacuees as well
these locations have been setting up
temporary beds and tents to receive
evacuees who in some cases are in the
middle of getting their visas to come to
the u.s
they have to go through a pretty
rigorous security process that could
sometimes take up to a year and so
they'll need to live in those third
countries for that duration while
they're waiting for their visas to come
through
there are currently a few pathways for
entry into the u.s evacuees with visas
or those who are in the visa application
process can enter
people who don't have visas are often
sent to a third country while a security
screening is completed those who work
for an american nonprofit or media
organization or individuals facing
political religious or ethnic
persecution can enter as refugees
there's also a fourth option an
immigration program known as parole
which gives evacuees temporary
permission to live and work in the u.s
once they're in the country they can
apply for asylum possibly get
sponsorship from family or wait for
their visa to come through those
arriving in the us are initially being
housed at military bases in new jersey
virginia wisconsin and texas while other
bases may eventually receive evacuees as
well
they're kind of being used as reception
centers in some cases we have to do
medical screenings on them before they
can get their visas in some cases
they're just being connected with
resettlement organizations in the united
states who are helping them you know get
connected to services here
many of these resettlement organizations
are contracted with the u.s government
the groups help evacuees find a place to
live and enroll their children in
schools with the aim of integrating them
into american life
anyone who gets here has been through an
extremely harrowing experience
and we have to remember those are the
lucky ones
[Music]